so while we were all distracted today by
the resignation of andrew cuomo another
big story was quietly unfolding on the
senate floor and this one actually
matters to you republicans and democrats
teamed up to sell the american taxpayer
up the river passing a one trillion
dollar
bipartisan infrastructure bill so what
does this mean well if you ask joe biden
it's all about jobs jobs jobs
create millions of jobs literally
not
not a seven dollar an hour jobs even 15
hours but jobs are prevailing wages
making 46 50 an hour with benefits it's
a bill that would end years of gridlock
in washington
and create millions of good paying jobs
it makes key investments that will one
create millions of good union jobs all
across the country
okay so that sounds pretty good on the
surface right i think we can all get
behind jobs and better roads and bridges
but not so fast if you do a little
digging you'll find the deal isn't as
sweet as it seems in fact billions of
dollars would go toward things that have
nothing to do with infrastructure at all
like radical equity and environmental
justice whatever that is but we can't be
surprised notice how it's mostly bad
ideas that get bipartisan support
members of both parties love nothing
more than to waste your money because
they don't care about you republican
senator josh hawley voted against that
infrastructure bill today and he joins
me now senator uh you know i understand
why the democrats voted for the bill
this is the part of their agenda joe
biden ran on this the radicals love it
why did your republican colleagues vote
for this bill you know good question i i
have to say i don't know the answer to
that question and i i'm disappointed
that anybody would support this bill you
said it exactly right this isn't an
infrastructure bill this is a radical
left woke politics bill that has stuff
like gender identity mandates in it the
radical equity agenda the green new deal
that's all in this bill and by the way
it's going to cost trillions of dollars
pork barrel spending there's stuff like
bridges and highways in canada in this
bill we've got to be building highways
and bridges in the united states not in
foreign countries this is a bad bill and
that's why i voted no so we those of us
that follow this for a living knew that
this was coming a lot of these
problem solvers they called themselves
were marching back and forth to the
white house and there was an agreement
that they were going to get real
infrastructure done but come to find out
the democrats just decided to get
another bill as well and put it on the
floor and they're going to vote for that
as well so did the republicans get
scammed again
yeah i'm afraid so i mean listen this is
all joe biden's agenda that's the key
thing to know this is the biden far left
agenda spending trillions of dollars to
remake our society and to remake it in
the image of the woke left that's what
he wants to do
and that's what he is succeeding in
doing right now and so it's absolutely
imperative that republicans say no this
is not the right vision for this country
we are not a racist country we're not an
evil country we're a good country we
don't need to be remade americans need
to be empowered to live their lives that
needs to be our agenda so the little
money that was there can americans
expect that the roads are going to be
improved and the bridges are going to be
improved and that you know life is going
to be made better with their tax dollars
on some type of front you know i don't
know about that i mean what it looks
like to me is over a trillion dollars in
pork barrel spending only a small
percentage of that actually goes to
roads and bridges and in my state
waterways which are important and what
do americans get stuck with they get
left with a massive tab that they're
going to have to pay for with increased
taxes and they get left with woke
politics which is what most of this bill
goes to pay for that's why it's such a
bad deal and that's why republicans need
to oppose it so
just to be clear senator uh republicans
conservatives they call themselves are
voting for tax increases because that's
the only way you pay for something like
this right yeah i mean right now what
the congressional budget office said
look hundreds of billions of dollars in
this in this terrible bill aren't paid
for it's gonna have to be paid for
somehow we all know how that works it's
working people who end up paying for it
with increased taxes i'll tell you what
else working people are going to be
paying for is increase food prices
increase prices for car repairs and
increase gas prices all of that because
of this out of control federal spending
and these far left policies and i say
again republicans need to put forward a
better alternative a better vision just
going along with the biden agenda that
is not the way all in the name of
bipartisanship i would love if one of
those republican senators would join me
tomorrow or any day this week to explain
why they ran with a conservative message
and they're not governor in that way i
think a lot of us are sick of that
people that are non-partisan
libertarians just people that believe in
improving the lives of americans um and
they just can't get the job done to me
senator thanks so much for coming on the
program thanks for having me hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else